elles sont revenus tout les trois
médaillés des championnats de france
individuels le 12 mai dernier à nice 17
ans et lee et hyaline 14 ans sont trois
gymnastes yvelinoise formé à la gemme
elancourt mort pas un club qui les a vu
éclore les filles qui ont beaucoup de
talent on essaye dans la mesure du
possible de développer encore plus ses
talents mais pour faire ce qu'elles font
il ya il ya des qualités innées même
avec du travail on pas les avoir ça fait
là presque 20 ans que j'entraîne
j'ai vu passer pas mal de gymnastes et
désigne avec autant de talent aussi bien
physique mental il a pas beaucoup pour
continuer à progresser les trois pépites
qui sont au club depuis plusieurs
saisons s'entraînent entre 12 et 20
heures par semaine sur ces agréé au
gymnase du bois mort pas et tout cela
dans un esprit familial la politique du
club
je pense que ça joue parce que quand
quelqu'un enfin quand par exemple
savamment bien sûr une séance sont là
pour me motiver ou m'encourager
moi pareil c'est le sera pas dans celle
ci on s'entraîne avec des filles qui
n'aiment pas va enfin à mon envie de
s'entraîner du coup à prendre
progressivement
un esprit familial qui est associé à
l'exigence du haut niveau objectif pour
les coaches repousser toujours plus
leurs limites au niveau l'action des
hanches haut niveau l'action des épaules
c'est encore tout petit elles peuvent
encore faire mieux
peuvent durcir les mouvements faire des
mouvements on va dire plus compliqué
plus long plus propres au site c'est une
des qualités de la saône à stx et le
côté artistique donc il faut de
l'exécution parfaite si on va voir des
bonnes notes et donc des médailles
prochain rendez vous pour ces pépites
les championnats de france par équipes
qui seront organisées du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les trois amis auront à coeur de
remporter des titres devant leur public
allez m